وانما ان تدعم حقوق كل المواطن ومواطن
لم ناتي لندمر ولندوس على الاخرين لنحافظ
ولهذا نحن سنتقدم وسنصحح بشكل مسؤول
لاعاده التوازن
المطلوب بين السلطات وهذا جزء واحد من
الكثير من
المسار الافضل لتحقيق الاصلاح لمنع الفقع
في الشارع هو التوصل الى التوافق عريض
للاسف
حتى هذه الساعه
ممثلوه المعارضه رفضوا الدخول في الحفاظ
منذ ثلاثه اشهر
اامل ان يتغير ايام المقبله اصغي
الطرف الاخر لكن انتبهوا
ذلك التغييرات في القانون هذا يتعلق
القانوني الذي سيطرح على
نسيطر على لجنه القضاه وانما نحدث توازن
وتنوع
ات
وهذا كان تم اقصاءه اللحظه لا نريد ان
يكون
محكمه تحت السيطره وانما ان تكون محكمه
متوازنه ومحكمه متوازنه ستكون محكمه الشعب
ى
وهذا ليس نهايه الديمقراطيه وانما
كل الديمقراطيات بما في ذلك الولايات
المتحده
الممثلون الجمهور هم من ينتخب
نهايه الديمقراطيه
الرجل القضاء
معروف من جامعه هارفار
ما الذي
اصلاح اذا كانت الاصلاح سيمر بدون هذه
التغييرات المتحده
هذا لدعم
الانخوف من الجانب الاخر وهناك مخاوف من
فقره تغلب جارفه وغير متوازنه حتى يكون
هناك الاغلبيه يمكن لها ان كل شيء هذا ليس
صحيح
لن يحدث ذلك العكس صحيح نحن وانا اريد ان
احافظ من خلال قانون على
حقوق الاساس